es sin duda el incidente de
ciberespionaje más relevante desde el
caso snow de un consorcio de 17 medios
investigo números de teléfono archivados
por el estado a través del software de
espionaje pedazos de escenas de
periodistas hombres y mujeres políticos
defensores de derechos humanos e incluso
jefes empresariales están preocupados
entre ellos el periodista mexicano
cecilio pineda asesinado en 2017 apenas
semanas después de ser puesto bajo
vigilancia o el séquito del periodista
saudita jamal cayón y asesinado en 2018
en estambul en su sitio web la sociedad
israelí en ese show lo atestigua pegasus
sirve en la lucha contra el terrorismo y
el crimen pero organizaciones como
forbidden stories y amnistía
internacional denuncian la desviación
del software de espionaje con fines
políticos amnistía internacional ya
había presentado una queja en 2019
contra la sociedad en esto una vez
alojado en un smartphone pegasus permite
tener acceso a los mensajes fotos y
contactos del dispositivo y también
escuchar las llamadas de su propietario
sin dejar el menor rastro